Here, g of f of 1 equals negative 2, and g of f of x equals 3x squared minus 6x
plus 1. Great solving, if you got these two right. For this first problem,
we'll start by finding the f of 1. We need to find the output, when the input
for f is 1. So letting x equal 1 here, and here, we'll have a new expression. 1
squared equals 1, negative 2 times 1 is negaitive 2 and then we'll have
positive 2 on the end. Summing these together we get a final output of positive
1. So, we know the output is 1 when x equals 1 for f. So, we can replace f of 1
with it's value, 1. Now we just need to find the g of 1. Plugging in 1 in for x
here, will get 3 times 1 minus 5, so that equals negative 2. This is how we
find g of f of 1. Now to find g of f of x we're going to take f of x this
entire function and we're going to plug it in for this x here. Remember f of x
is going to be the input for g. So wherever we see x for g we replace that with
x squared minus two x plus 2. We distribute the positive 3 to get 3 x squared
minus 6x plus 6. Then we just combine the like terms on the end, to get 3x
squared minus 6x plus 1, g of f of x.